hey Theo I had a self-esteem question
for you man so okay thanks for calling
oh and in middle school I gained a whole
bunch of weight I was a heavy boy I'm
from the south as well the wonder when I
gained Wow a lot of southerners today
thank you for calling you get you gain
some weight in middle school let's go
water weight I developed breasts oh boy
did I tell you this store are you making
me think about this right now and I'm
not I'm not trying to interrupt you but
I'm going to I'm gonna interrupt you for
a second man they had this big boy when
I was growing up and dude he got them
first he got them tots first you know
and had one girl in school that had him
but she was uh you know she her family
was you know heavily with the Lord and
they're deadlocked you know they kept
they call the kids locked up in the yard
and about a year and a half later I felt
in a feeling her breath through the book
through a barbed-wire fence you know
catching that Tet you know catching that
tight a with my palm just palming down
their frickin young I don't know if it
was a tit yeah but it was gonna be at it
you know it was on a girl so and that
still counts and she let me touch that
warm lump and we were both children so
that's totally legal but I remember I
used to go sleep at my buddy's house
because he got tits kind of first you
know and he was a bigger boy but man I'd
sleep over there dude a month dude I
swear man my penis would get so hard bro
not at him but at the tits and I would
even put my hands like this it's because
I saw I wouldn't see the rest of his
body I would just see the breasts you
know because I wasn't thinking about men
I was just thinking about tits you know
and so I would just see it you know I
would just make a little kind of squint
area like I see them big beautiful you
know them just flash bulbs of straight
up you know them straight up leche
duffels you know them beautiful bags and
that's and I would love that man and
that's a man I was just getting so keyed
up and fired up and I remember I get so
erect sometimes as a child I'll pass out
I'd be unconscious
because I would get you know because I'm
thinking that you know I got that I'm
that I got that strong you know I got I
got it's not really a baby arm I got
it's like two baby's arms and his legs
and he's standing straight up with his
arms and legs like that you know just in
a straight line I got that I got that
capacity I got that [ __ ] pasady and so
when that thing takes on the blood when
it doesn't all call for that blood and
that hemoglobin do when everything
rushes into daddies you know into that
big into that ballast tank the rest of
me kind of sometimes will just faint I
used to get erect and faint a lot as a
child but I remember first breasts I
ever saw on a beautiful thick boy in my
neighborhood and a friend of mine he was
and and I'll say this man that there's
nothing wrong with that let's hear more
van kitty
they've been there ever since no man
kitty okay you got the man been there
ever since I'm 27 now I've lost a lot of
weight even in the past in the past year
I've lost 40 pounds Wow congratulations
man I can't even imagine that
I can't even imagine the
stick-to-itiveness it's taken to do that
so I hope you feel a lot of pride in
yourself man I hope that you know people
say to me a lot dear you should take a
moment and think of you know where you
were before in certain aspects your life
can even be a couple weeks ago with an
attitude and where you are now but I
hope you recognize that man that's a
huge thing to lose 40 pounds and you
must feel a lot of pride let's hear more
so the thing that what what stuff man is
uh the self-esteem is low man you take
you know I'm going to the beach next
weekend with my family and the idea of
taking my shirt off and being around the
beach is terrible you know I've been to
the beach before man and I try to like
make light of the situation you know I
was kind of like toe jokes about like
how uh how it's okay for me to take my
shirt off because I'm a male even though
I have titties bigger than you know half
the females on the beach I mean uh yeah
man I'm kind of feeling a little bit
sorry that I was met you know I wasn't
making fun earlier but I was telling you
a story that kind of I guess correlated
just maybe some of these
those things might have you know kind of
I don't hope I hope that didn't bum you
out at all because I really enjoyed
seeing that on my friends but you know I
can imagine what it was like for him and
now I'm kind of learning that
perspective let's hear some more it's
trying to figure out man like how can I
like embrace it you know and surgery is
an option but it's about you know yeah
that surgery I know it's about five to
7,500 and then you also have to wear
special shirts and stuff at agreein and
then you have to take about two weeks
off of work all right man I you know I
appreciate that call man it's brave to
call about that you know I mean if
you're nervous you know I'll save you a
couple things one if you're nervous
about the surgery you know obviously I'm
sure you've probably researched and talk
to people and you can find other people
that have had it I have a friend
actually a comedian friend who was just
telling me the other day that he had
this same issue and then he ended up
having the surgery and that finally
after years a lot of that inferiority
and I don't know if that shame but you
know just that nervousness has gone away
from him because obviously he's you know
his body looks different now but that
that ran real heavily with him for a
while yeah man that's tough because you
want to just have your shirt off and
just be at the beach and feel free you
know you want to maybe even get fully
naked and have a damn uh you know uh you
know uh a turkey burger or a um little
baby Julius Berger what is that thing
called a sloppy joe not baby Julius what
am I thinking of whoo and so you want to
have you almost want to get fully naked
and have a sloppy joe I'm trying to
think of I wish there was a special
shirt that was for a dope-ass man that
had some kind of little bit of light you
know kind of thicker and that you know
then breasticles you know I wish they
had a man like you know that could kind
of you know like a man's ear you know
just kind of something you know even if
Under Armour made one or something you
know so I don't know I mean I guess oh
it's tough too because I know that
probably is tough for you
yeah I mean I if I for me personally
what would I do I would probably wear
some type of Under Armour type of thing
where I could still be athletic a little
bit and get some Sun but I would still
be able to take care of that part of me
where I didn't you you know if it's
gonna make you so self-conscious that
you're not going to be able to enjoy
yourself at all then maybe for now I
would still you know maybe wear a shirt
because because here's the thing you're
going to the beach you want to have fun
you don't want to not be able to enjoy
yourself so you know for now I would do
what's you know what's gonna make you
feel okay and bring you the most joy now
say you go full throttle you know when
you got there made coupes out there you
know you got them you know them
lowercase a is out there then I think
have some fun you know have some fun I
mean accept the fact that you're
probably gonna get some looks know that
in advance and then maybe have some fun
with it
now here's a fun thing you could do you
could get one of those Tahitian type of
things with the coconut bra things you
know like Fred Flintstone wears because
that's something that's fun and it's all
would still kind of you know cover up
some of your nervousness so maybe that's
something fun that you could do you know
but um you know if it continues to
bother you I don't think there's any
shame in getting a surgical procedure if
you can afford it I don't know how that
works with with with insurance or
anything like that but you know what man
let me I want to know how that beach
goes and even if it doesn't go well I
want to know that if you wouldn't mind
you know I'd love to circle back with
you and find out just kind of the truth
if you can take me through some more
that you know because I know that that
kind of stuff is tough man when we feel
our bodies are a certain way man I've
always hated like the slope of my
shoulders dude I gotta do it ever since
I was young it's a little better a
little different now but I had a real
des booty I had the same but buttocks
and hips had a lot of down syndrome
men and women had and a lot of black
girls we had the same butt and so I'd
always get all these wild jokes and you
know I'd feel nervous everybody wanted
me to twerk all the time and [ __ ]
I'm like [ __ ] you know so I feel you man
it's tough it's tough when we live in
this world that puts so much on how we
look and and we're so self-aware too and
then we have this you know something
that really stands out I mean dude I
wish I could wear a brassiere over my
nose sometimes you know I got a you know
I got a my nose it's kind of a c-cup so
I got that c-cup whiffer but thanks for
calling man and for just for not
thinking and not feeling that stuff
alone if you go out to the beach hope
you have a foot I hope you have a blast
no matter how you no matter how you play
it I hope you have a blast man thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz this is alarming